ich möchte mich bei ihnen entschuldigen
wie unendlich von mir dass ich ihr
eigentum angefasst habe kulig war nun
also wird ja ich kann ihnen versichern
es war um böse absicht darf ich ihn
wieder erklimmen dafür taugt ihm ist
eine der erstaunlichsten arbeiten die
ihnen wird zurzeit im kino auf uns
zugekommen ist eine horror-komödie im
weitesten sinne ein film der auf einer
möglichen die gänse weise mit sieben
regel richtung zu gleichen grund 1
jamara film ist es hat mich gefreut
cancellara
für die meisten jungen paare kommt
irgendwann der moment in dem sie sehen
ob die sache ernst wird und deshalb oft
mit einem ereignis zu tun das im
amerikanischen kino und auch in anderen
erzähltradition eine große rolle spielt
suche bei den eltern bedürftiger eltern
viel mut ein junges amerikanisches paris
und rose machen sich auf die arme patch
der junge mann nach seinen
antrittsbesuch bei der familie seiner
freundin ein wichtigste teil hat rose
allerdings ihren eltern verschwiegen
vermutlich mit bedacht
allerdings sollte das in einem liberalen
ausfalls über den armeechef es im grunde
keine rolle spielen
es stellt sich allerdings heraus dass es
eine sehr sehr große rolle spielt dass
es an diesem wochenende das quiz bei der
familie verbringen wird um nichts
anderes geht als um die frage was macht
hautfarbe in einer gesellschaft in der
amerikanischen der junge regisseur war
bisher eigentlich nur eingeweihten ein
begriff allerdings hat er durchaus form
ein großes maß an popularität vor allem
in amerika
weil nämlich vor allem als comedian
bekannt ist in jedem moment ist es aber
auch ein hochpolitischer film bei dem
sehr interessant die amerikanische
politische gegenwart ins spiel kommt so
ganz mit ihrer papiere
ich will nicht wissen wer gefahren ist
ist sein ausraster
das ist ein phänomen des rassismus in
amerika auf eine seltsame weise
beschäftigt und er was auf eine weise
die komödien vor - das war
wahrscheinlich eine weise
zusammenbringen wie man das aus den
besten beispielen der amerikanischen
unterhaltungsindustrie kennt in der sich
immer darum geld zu verdienen mit denen
die nebenbei vielleicht auch noch
intelligent sind als bestes und das ist
bei geld auf in hohem maße der fall
einer der besten einer der
unterhaltsamsten wenn oder klügsten
filme seit langer zeit lassen sie den
scheinwerfer reparieren und den spiegel
dank afrikas
[Musik]